okay guys we are here at PAX East 2015
I'm Alexa ray Korea and I'm here with
Peter Brown and we just played overwatch
what is overwatch Peter why that's why
there's new first-person shooter Alexa
but no I mean they've shut this off at
previous events who is Khan for example
today they had two new characters in a
new map he's telling me about the first
new character he's got kind of like a
Wild West thing going they did his name
is McCready and he's sort of a a
gunslinger gone bad gone good he used to
be in munition smuggling and Train
Robbery like their typical like banditry
and overwatch caught him and they said
all right you have a choice you know
join us or you go rot in a jail cell
he'll be joined overwatch and he's a
typical shooter he's a sharpshooter and
his special abilities are he has a he
has a peacekeeper revolver and it's got
six shots and if you're a sniper the
great thing about it is if you're a
sniper you can stand high up and kick
people off one by one or you can get
really up-close and shoot people
point-blank so he stood at both ranges
he's really good against like bigger
characters like Reinhardt cuz he can
literally shoot them point blank and
blow them up his ultimate let's you let
you do six shots continuously and that's
really good at short range
she's also accurate someone as you
meters away so I'm told I didn't get to
test that out in the game but he also
has a stun grenade and if you shoot if
you throw it out you get like 20 seconds
and anyone caught him it will stop this
is actually really good against tracer
she's really fast but this makatsch even
got a pretty decent sun minute so McCree
sounds pretty good I played as him a
little bit I'll get to that in a second
but I want to know about the other
characters Daria Daria I love Daria
she's a tank together
she's one of the characters that
Blizzard has specifically said they've
designed her to be a more more diverse
normally you see little tiny pretty
girls tiny waist big chest she's a
former Russian professional bodybuilder
so she's just huge hulking big muscles
gorgeous I love it and in coal ore
she is a former weightlifter and she
left a professional weightlifting to
help humanity in the Omni crisis in
overwatch like you do like you do I did
already mentioned that she is a tank and
she has a particle cannon which is her
main weapon and primarily she's really
good at firing short-range beams but she
can also hold hold it on someone for a
while and training on them and shoot a
more powerful beam at them or she can
shoot out a part of a grenade that will
explode and take out anything in its
path she can put a particle barrier over
herself or on one Ally and it's a sphere
that absorbs damage and also sort of
tampers with the gravity of the
situation like you can throw you can
have someone else throw a can a prince
or throw a time bomb in it and it will
you know alter the time in the sphere
and anything caught in it would be
affected and while she's got a sphere
out it charges her gut so it makes her
fun more powerful her ultimate is a
graviton surge and it's a ranged attack
that can stick to walls or the ceiling
to the floor and that's another gravity
shifting option I really like playing as
her I think she's very bandy in battle I
liked her more than I liked the tree
very taut yeah okay and so I mean any no
I don't play a ton of first-person
shooters but playing overwatch I
definitely felt like the mechanics were
there and it had that Blizzard charm in
the art style that's irresistible to say
the least I mean I think everyone can
find a character that appeals to them
who's your character my character McCree
was pretty cool there was a guy right
next to him who looked like mitsurugi
from Soul Calibur that I wanted to play
on but alas we didn't have a whole lot
of time because there is a massive line
for overwatch huge line and we played a
little bit and we got our asses kicked
handed to us and I have to wonder is it
because we're just bad at those games
maybe but it was definitely the
experience of a hardcore competitive
shooter that we've sort of jumped into
as novices yeah and maybe while that
didn't appeal to us that's the sort of
thing that kept people who are really
into that genre I think are going to
like because
it's a blizzard game but it's also very
challenging it's not just a walk in the
park in the beginning you know as you
sort of find your footing it's tough
from the get-go it is very challenging
and it's also very charming and that's
what appeals to me I'm not a shooter
player not a MOBA player I know they
have a lot of eSports potential there
have an eSports initiative that they
want for that game but I really liked it
I think it's something that could get me
into that really yeah there you go
that's overwatch from pax east of 2015
it's only the first day of the show just
a tune in gamespot.com over the next
three days for a lot more concept